It would be nice if you could tell me why, it's
fine, so there's no point in
saying it anyway, you probably won't understand anyway
.
I
don't know what's good about what you're saying I'm not a banker
Why do you say it's a cool house
?
Why is there a sin-7
Sound is good School is good In the first place what is chaos?
It
's kind of cool when your right arm tingles There's
no way to feel like you can't control your power What's with
that?
It's
just Belgium in a village you're used to. Don't hide it and take it in with all your strength
.
It's almost mai
Okay, stop your legs
[music] It's
okay bandana Just do a
little research and it all depends on what
's going on I don't know what it means unless you tell me what it means
If so, it's the Dala district.It
's a military department, and it's a lavalon.
You can't use art words
If you look it up, who was bought by your words is a
logger?
yeah yeah yeah